Speaker 1: . All right. This I think you're going
to love Mike Pillow is back and now he's praying
for me. And he seems to have no memory that we did
a beautiful, extensive interview on the program,
just like, I don't know, a year ago or something
like that. So let's kind of go back to the
beginning. Some of you may remember there's this
guy, Mike Lindell. He's the CEO and founder of
Mypillow. He showed up with National, a kind
of presence at the beginning of the pandemic.
Donald Trump brought him to the White House and
he said, oh, we're going to make masks, we're
going to make all these different things. And he
believed Donald Trump was selected by God and is
generally kind of a wacky guy. Then Mike Pillow,
as we now know him or just Pillow was rocketed to
fame, not necessarily stardom, but I guess fame
notoriety maybe is a better word in fighting for
the overturning of the 2020 presidential election
in just about every state he claims Trump won like
California, you know, wacky, wacky stuff. And at a
certain point, I interviewed him and the interview
was super interesting. I mean, I don't know that
we really were convinced that indeed Trump won.
But it was interesting to hear from Mike Pillow,
and the interview did very well on our channel.
A few weeks ago, the real Mike Pillow showed
up on our Facebook page and started making all
sorts of allegations and accusations against me.
And we went back to him and we said, Hey, listen,
we'd love to have you back on the program. And so
far it hasn't happened. Well, over the weekend,
he showed up again in the comments of our YouTube
channel. There was a post just like a funny little
post about the bonus show. It's a picture of me
with my baby daughter, and I'm having one of my
globally famous and much despised cappuccinos.
And it's just fun. That's all it is. And the
real Mike Lindell verified account shows up and
says, Praying for you, David, you don't know me,
but you sure enjoy attacking me. Would love to
have you on my show. Well, permission granted,
sir. I would love to be on the Mike Pillow Show.
We are trying to get him back on our program to
get the latest updates about, you know, the
machines and all of this different stuff.
Speaker 3: We're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines. Over 54
countries have now been taken by the machines.
Speaker 1: Exactly. I would love to have him back
on. He his his people don't seem to be allowing
him to do it, or at least not really telling him.
I don't know. He seems eager, but they don't.
And I would love to be on his program. And one
of the funniest things is he seems to genuinely
have no recollection of the fact that we do know
each other. We have each other's numbers. He's
been on the program. We talked on the show. We
talked off the show. I know he's he's a busy
guy, but you would think with the amount of time
he's spending on my Facebook page, he would have
some memory of the fact that we did an interview.
And Haley actually pointed out to him, you've
literally been a guest on his show within the
last year, and that is absolutely true. So pillow
increasingly spending time on my Facebook page,
which in a way I love and I'm flattered. And the
funniest thing about this, this is like a little
behind the scenes thing. Producer Pat not long ago
was trying to get the interview booked with Pillow
after he made these comments. There is no doubt
that it's the real mike pillow. Okay. When you
click, it goes to his a verified page with 150,000
followers. This is Pillow's real Facebook account,
his staff said to Pat. We very much doubt that
he's been commenting on David's Facebook videos.
They don't seem to be willing to
either accept it or look into it,
but it's pillow and he's welcome on the show and
I would love to be on his show. One of the most
interesting and depraved characters of this entire
global nightmare that has been MAGA Trumpism